quand j'étais à l'école j'étais harcelé
j'avais peur je me sentais seule
j'aurais voulu qu'on prenne ma défense
tout cela est derrière moi mais je pense
surtout à ceux qui le vivent aujourd'hui
victime témoins et équipe éducative
parents on peut tous agir contre le
harcèlement pour savoir que faire et qui
contacter rendez-vous sur agir contre le
harcèlement à
l'école.gouof.fr ce soir dans le 78
société nous allons donc parler du
harcèlement à l'école comment le
détecter quels sont les signes qui
doivent aderter comment le prévenir et
quelles réponses sont à apporté une
enquête réalisée par l'UNICEF et
l'Observatoire international de la
violence à l'école a montré que dou 12 %
des élèves de CE2 CM1 CM2 sont victimes
de harcèlement de modéré à sévère 10 %
des collégiens et 3,4 % des lycéens le 6
février dernier la ministre Najat Valo
Belkassem a présenté son plan
anti-harcèlement pour la ministre de
l'Éducation nationale il faut rompre le
silence et agir sur deux points la
formation des enseignants et la prise en
charge des familles alors pour en parler
avec nous trois personnes référentes
dans le département C valfredini bonsoir
vous êtes proviseur vie scolaire vous
assurer des missions de conseiller
technique auprès du Directeur Académique
pour toutes les questions qui concernne
la vie scolaire et la vie des
établissement Karina ggou bonsoir vous
êtes conseillère au sein du
c2a2e c'est le centre académique d'aide
aux écoles et aux établissements et
enfin Chantal pon Rossillon bonsoir vous
êtes assistante sociale alors la
première question que j'ai envie de vous
poser comment on peut définir le
harcèlement qu'est-ce qui est peut-être
plus du jeu mais qui devient de la
violence alors c'est une définition
assez ancienne puisquelle date des
années 70 et c'est la répétition de fait
de violence très souvent des
microvolences rien de forcément
spectaculaire et quelque chose qui va
s'installer dans le temps et donc les
violences peuvent être physiqu
psychologique et s'installer assez
durablement la difficulté c'est que la
répétition n'est pas tous les jours
toutes les heures mais de manière
beaucoup plus insidieuse donc
l'harcèlement c'est la répétition
c'est pas simplement se bousculer une
fois c'est quand on commence à se faire
bousculer plusieurs fois vous dites un
type de harcèlement psychologique c'est
quoi c'est quand on on a des surnoms
dans cours des mauvais surnoms des
moqueries des fois c'est pas méchant
mais ça commence par par des mocerie
souvent effectivement des surnoms mais
ça peut être aussi l'isolement tu es
plus ma copine et je te parle plus tu
fais plus partie de la bande ça j'ai
envie de vous dire ça arrive fréquemment
ça arrive fréquemment mais c'est très
très dur à vivre pour les enfants d'être
tout le temps choisi en dernier dans une
équipe par exemple sur le coup on a
l'impression que c'est anoda sauf que
pour l'enfant qui le vit ça peut être
très violent et euh la les rumeurs aussi
hein malheureusement font beaucoup de
mal aussi aux enfants et en terme de
harcèlement psychologique c'est c'est
assez fort pour pour celui qui le vit
vous allez nous dire hein tous les
conseils surtout qu'on peut donner aux
parents comment on peut prendre en
compte la parole de l'enfant et puis
évidemment le travail aussi amener
auprès des des enseignants mais je
voudrais d'abord qu'on écoute les
cquantinois le harcèlement à l'école
qu'est-ce que ça vous évoque question
que nous sommes allés poser dans les
rues de 50 anine non pas pas mes enfants
étent à l'école ils ont pas eu de
problème particulier donc ça existe oui
mais bon heureusement on n pas été
touché par ce phénomène dans mon enfance
je crois comme nous tous euh on a déjà
subi ces ces petites brimades ces
petites moqueries qui ressemble plus ou
moins à l'harcèlement et c'est un
passage un petit peu obligatoire tant
que ça reste du léger ça a peut-être
pris plus d'ampleur depuis le les
téléphones portables avec les vidéos
qu'on peut faire le harcèlement qui se
fait via les les
sites les réseaux sociaux c'est le mot
que je cherchais euh oui oui oui moi et
mes proches ouais et c'est des trucs
c'est des trucs de gosse quoi enfin
parce que tu as pas le bon vêtement ou
parce que tu as pas le dernier truc à la
mode ou des choses comme ça évidemment
quand on est victime de harcèlement
c'est quelque chose qu'on ressemble mal
après je pense qu'il faut en parler
avant tout que soit c'est responsable
pédagogique so à ses proches à ses
parents et ce en parler et puis je pense
que c'est en en parlant justement que
les choses elles peuvent mieux se se
dénouer quoi alors en parlant il y avait
beaucoup de choses intéressante dans ce
micro trottoir on a notamment entendu la
question autour des téléphones portables
ça on parlera du cyber harcèlement parce
que ça existe et c'est une vraie réalité
mais la première question c'est comment
on prend en compte la parole la parole
de l'enfant quand on est parent qu'on
est confronté à un enfant qui rentre de
l'école et dit bon je me suis fait
bousculer une fois deux fois bout trois
fois qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire quand on
est parent alors quand il arrive à à
parler je dirais que c'est euh c'est
c'est à ce moment-là ça peut être plus
facile parce que bien souvent il ne parl
pas et euh et de fait si il parle il
faut absolument effectivement prendre en
compte ce que dit l'enfant et et ne pas
minimiser justement comme là ça pu on a
pu l'entend sor un monsieur qui dit bah
ça fait parti c'est obligatoire quoi
c'est passage obligé même on a
l'impression à l'école et en fait les
justement puisquil y a du recul dans les
et les observations et et les recherches
c'est bien le fait de l'accumul tion qui
à un moment donné fait cette a des
répercussions graves euh mais justement
comme c'est fait de façon très
insidieuse et que l'acte en lui-même
peut être un petit fait je dirais une
bousculade une insulte et d'autres faits
de ce genre mais qui en soi
effectivement ne sont pas très
importants et du coup ce n'est pas pris
en compte à la hauteur de ce que ça
représente je dirais par le monde des
adultes y compris par des parents qui
ont pu avoir vécu jeune de ce type de
de difficult enfant parle peut-être la
solution la plus simple mais si l'enfant
ne parle pas est-ce qu'il y a quand même
des signes qui doivent alerter alors
c'est tout ce qui est de l'or je dirais
de la rupture c'est qu'un enfant qui a a
un comportement
différent et qui s'installe au fil des
jours et souvent là quand j'ai les
parents au téléphone ils me disent voilà
au début il était un peu plus triste ou
il était il avait moins envie de ou
alors somatise beaucoup hein chez chez
les les plus jeunes notamment les
enfants qui peuvent somatiser beaucoup
coup ils ont mal au ventre ils ont mal C
ils ont mal là ils ont un jour ils ont
plus vraiment envie d'aller à l'école et
donc là aussi on est sur un c'est une
accumulation je dirais de de de
phénomènes qui qui qui doivent
absolument interpeller les parents et
qui là doivent du coup absolument
intégrer le harcèlement dans les
questionnements qu'ils doivent avoir par
rapport à ce qu'ils observent chez leur
enfants vous voulez je
vois effectivement alors c'est compliqué
parce qu' effffectivement ce sont des
signes de malêtre mais qui peuvent être
liés à un décès dans la famille qui
peuvent être lié à une situation
familiale nouvelle donc on n'a pas
forcément en tête en tant que parent
l'idée que c'est forcément lié à une
situation d'école et une situation de
harcèlement mais effectivement ça doit
faire partie des des hypothèses des
pistes sur lesquelles on on peut
interroger l'enfant sans forcément lui
demander est-ce que tu es harcelé ouais
c'est ça alors interroger l'enfant et
pas forcément d'abord l'inquiéter on lui
parlant tout de suite de harcèlement que
ça prenne il y a des mots à utiliser des
des des questions à poser qui
automatiquement peuvent déclencher
quelqu
je dirais des questionnements simples
comment ça se passe à l'école et tes
copains ça va s'intéresser à la vie de
l'enfant à son enfant à l'école au
quotidien sans pour autant être dans des
grands questionnement mais par des
petits indices on peut arriver à à
cerner un petit peu l'état de son enfant
dans ses relations avec ses camarades
quand on a entendu le micro trop oui
pardon oui je je voudrais rebondir parce
que dans dans ce que j'entends aussi
c'est euh des parents qui ont pu
intervenir et puis sans qu'il est
vraiment une prise en compte du du
harcelllement et qui disent qui me
disent bon un jour j'ai il a plus rien
dit et et du coup effectivement ne
s'interroge plus he par rapport
notamment à ce type de de problème alors
que l'enfant continue et que pour
quelques raisons donc il s'est arrêté de
parler notamment parce qu'il a perdu
confiance dans le monde des adultes et
alors aussi ce qui revient assez souvent
ce sont des parents qui là au niveau
quand les les les jeunes ont 13 14 ans
15 ans mett ça sur le compte de la crise
adolescence et euh et alors que on est
sur des replis sur soi très importants
he des jeunes qui par exemple ne
participent plus du tout à la vie
familiale au quotidien s'enfer dans leur
chambres ne prennent plus leur repas
avec leur les parents ou la famille et
et là et et donc des parents qui se
disent mais ça doit être la crise
d'adolescence tellement c'est violent
justement alors que un jour il découvre
que c'était bien le harcèement qui
provoqué he toutes ces et et il faut
donc je vrais quand même rebondir ce que
disait une personne interque bon c'est
un peu le passage obligé je trouve ça un
peu dur d'entendre ça parce que c'est
pas forcément un passage obligé le
harcèlement à l'école mais malgré tout
les conséquences peuvent être très
importantes et peut-être ça c'est
souvent minoré par mes connaissances pas
forcément parce que on veut mettre des
illères devant ses yeux mais c'est
souvent parce que par mes connaissances
on on ne mesure pas le le poids du ement
après sur une vie d'adulte on a entendu
ce ce jeune homme parler il a été
harcelé visiblement il encore voilà il a
un poid on sentait encore bah ça a des
conséquences tout simplement scolaires
en fait parce qu'un enfant qui est tout
le temps stressé en se demandant ce qui
va lui arriver quand il va quitter la
salle ou quel qui va lui tomber dessus
c'est difficile à ce moment-là d'être
concentré sur son travail sur la
multiplication qui qui est à effectuer
donc déjà ça a des conséquences sur le
les résultats scolaires et puis ensuite
sur la santé hein certains chercheurs
ont même des dé monrer un un lien entre
le harcènement et des difficultés de
croissance chez certains enfants donc
effectivement la la somatisation peut
être telle que ça provoque des des
effets tout à fait néfastes sur la santé
sur l'estime de soi so ouais je vous
propose maintenant d'écouter nicole
Catheline elle est pédosychiatre et elle
nous décrit justement les conséquences
pour les personnes
harcelées le stress généré par le le
harcèlement est à l'origine d'une baisse
des défens immunitaire va donc provoquer
différentes maladies ou somatisation
anxieuse à type de maux de ventre maux
de tête cela peut également provoquer
des troubles du sommeil des troubles
alimentaires cette ambiance anxueuse
peut même aboutir à des états dépressif
voire à des tentatives de suicide
également les harcelés ont plus de
risque à l'âge adulte de faire des états
dépressifs et enfin le dernier point
c'est qu'il y a une transmission
générationnel de des phénomènes de
harcèlement puisque les enfants qui ont
été harcelés devenant parents ont à leur
tour des enfants qui ont plus de risque
d'être harcelés voilà pour les
conséquences on mesure l'importance
alors que faire maintenant lorsque le
harcèlement est est connu donc on a on a
vu que les les parents pouvaient
intervenir mais au niveau du du corps
enseignant au niveau de de l'Académie
qu'est-ce qui est mis en place pour
soutenir à la fois ses enfants et ses
parents alors déjà souvent le premier
réflexes des parents c'est d'aller voir
l'école donc de s'adresser soit au à
l'enseignant
soit à la direction de l'école ou du
collège bon déjà c'est c'est un bon
réflexe parce que on a aussi certains
parents qui qui veulent régler un peu
tout seul la situation qui n'hésite pas
à aller frapper à la porte du parent du
gamin supposait harceleur et là souvent
ça a des conséquences un peu
désastreuses voir attraper le harceleur
et faire un peu justice tout tout seul
ce qui résou
rement les problèmes voilà après les
établissements suivent depuis 2 ans un
protocole en fait et ont obligation de
rencontrer la victime le harceleur les
témoins les parents de chacun et
d'informer évidemment la communauté de
manière à ce que il y ait une vigilance
vraiment plus plus plus de tous les
adultes h alors après cette vigilance
des adultes qu'est-ce qui se qu'est-ce
qui se passe est-ce qu'il y a forcément
des rencontres entre les parents
d'enfants harcelés les parents d'enfants
harceleurs est-ce que en règle générale
processus qui se met forcément en place
en règle générale on évite de faire
rencontrer le harcelé et le harceleur
puisque puisque le le harceleur par par
nature je dirais à une personnalité
assez lisse n'est pas capable vraiment
de d'être en capacité d'avoir de
l'empathie pour sa victime et et dans ce
cas-là ça renforce un peu la situation
de harcèlement donc le harceleur et le
harcelé je dirais leurs situations sont
examinées de manière très très distincte
mais mais mais vous vous rencontrer
quand même les familles alors les les
familles au sein des établissements
scolaires dans le protocole il est
préconisé que des équipes éducatif soit
organisé à la fois pour le harceler et
pour le harceleur après quand les
familles
contacte la plateforme stop harcèlement
et que les fiches à ce moment-là
reviennent dans le
département donc chantalpon se rapproche
des familles et moi je je me rapproche
des établissements scolaires pour faire
un point sur la situation et et faire
des préconisations au directeur
d'établissement c'est quoi par exemple
des préconisations c'est séparer changer
de
classeisement des selon les situations
ça peut être un changement de classe ça
peut être
peut-être il manque un acteur dans les
équipes
éducatives ça peut être éventuellement
que l'on se déplace dans les
établissements pour expliquer le
phénomène de harcèlement euh tout type
de tout type de situations peuvent se
présenter et donc au niveau des des
familles quelle action vous vous menez
alors alors c'est c'est de
l'accompagnement euh d'abord une écoute
un des des familles qui des parents et
qui ont découvert à un moment donné que
leurs enfants ont beaucoup souffert donc
ça justifie une une vraie écoute de les
rassurer de les rassurer sur le fait que
c'est c'est normal qu'ils ai pas pu
découvrir forcément suffisamment tôt
suffisamment à temps par que les par
doivent énormément se sentir coupable he
ces moment-là donc quand ils découvrent
effectivement ils sont envahis de
culpabilité parce qu'ils découvrent
effectivement que justement le
harcèlement au travers de petits actes
de violence quotidienne quasi
quotidienne euh ça ça ça ça provoque
chez l'enfant euh beaucoup de dégâts et
et beaucoup de souffrance et jusqu'à
perdre justement notamment toute
confiance dans le monde des adultes donc
les écouter les accompagner les rassurer
sur le fait que nous allons intervenir
et donc là on mobilise effectivement
toutes les équipes alors au niveau de la
direction académique nous travaillons
euh madame valfreddine et moi avec le
médecin responsable départemental et
l'infirmière responsable départemental
et chacun je dirais de nos services se
rapproche de de nos collègues dans les
établissements
pour justement aller au plus près de
l'enfant
et passer le relet je dirais aux équipes
des établissements et les
accompagner les équipes parce que c'est
vrai c'est compliqué c'est très
insidieux et ça peut être très compliqué
souvent les harceleurs sont dans le
dénis des actes
qu'il qu'il provoquent et qu'il mettent
en œuvre dis quoi en règle générale il
disent B c'était pour rigoler céit pas
méchant c'était alors quand ils en sont
là c'est déjà pas mal ah ah bon d'accord
reconnaissent il y en a qui
reconnaissent tout de suite qui disent
ben je me rendais pas compte il y en a
qui minimisent complètement et puis il y
en a qui sont dans le déni total et tant
qu'ils sont dans le déni et que les
adultes n'ont pas pu justement arrêter
le phénomène notamment parce queil aussi
des témoins qui qui sont tout autour là
qui verse d'un côté ou de l'autre ça
peut durer très longtemps et c'est
souvent là où les parents téléphonent à
la à la plateforme national donc donc
voilà l'idée c'est de les accompagner et
dans les aussi les préconisations qu'on
peut poser quand quand on entend euh
alors soit c'est au niveau de premier
échange téléphonique mais souvent
justement quand il rencontre
l'infirmière et ou le médecin scolaire
pour évaluer la l'état psychologique de
l'enfant l'état global même somatique
enfin l'état global pour évaluer
l'impact
psychologique de sur l'enfant et et voir
justement s'il y a une nécessité qu'il a
des
consultations spécialisées éventuell
ement pour soutenir l'enfant et ça
soutiendra aussi les parents voilà donc
on est beaucoup dans l'accompagnement de
ces situations et on arrête
d'accompagner quand nous sommes sûrs que
l'enfant retrouve une place d'élèves
ordinaire normal tranquille et ça vous
me dites c'est depuis 2 ans c'est
vraiment mis en place depuis 2 ans c'est
je rappelle qu'en novembre 2013
effectivement Vincent payon avait lancé
la campagne agir contre l'harcèlement à
l'école et puis la ministre Najat Valou
belcassen a réaffirmé effectivement
l'importance de lutter contre
l'harcèlement à l'école je voudrais
parce que vous avez parlé de cette
plform nationale rappelez qu'il y a deux
numéros verts il y a d'abord un numéro
vert stop harcèlement qui va qui va
s'afficher voilà qui permet de dialoguer
avec des des spécialistes de
l'association école des parents et des
éducateurs
d'île-de-fance ça permet donc une écoute
un conseil mise en relation avec le
référent harcèlement de l'Académie donc
en cas de de de besoin et puis un autre
numéro vert c'est un numéro net écoute
et là c'est un numéro de de téléphone
qui est qui sert en cas de cyber
harcèlement alors on entendu dans le
microrottoir effectivement parler des
téléphones portables le cyberhcèlement
c'est une une vraie réalité c'est une
nouvelle réalité dans les formes
d'harcèlement nouvelle réalité et là où
le le harcelé autrefois était à peu près
tranquille à la maison il avait au moins
un temps de pause la difficulté du
cyberhcèlement c'est qu'il est
finalement victime en permanence bah
souvent d'insultte de ou de rumeurs ou
de de diffusion de photos évidemment à
son
désavantage et là du coup c'est vraiment
compliqué parce que le
le harcèlement rentre vraiment au sein
de de la maison et au sein de de la
chambre de l'enfant h alors selon la
ministre un élève sur 5 a été victime un
jour de cyber violence je trouve ce
chiffre très important mais c'est comme
vous dites c'est c'est c'est facile en
fait parce que les réseaux sociaux sont
sont très utilisés par les par les oui
et puis pas forcément accompagné par les
adultes donc là je pense qu'il y a
vraiment un un pan de formation à avoir
autant sur le harcèlement que sur le
cyberhcèlement et puis apprendre à nos
jeunes aussi bah à maîtriser la sécurité
leur paramètres de compte à ne pas
diffuser d'information être très prudent
hein sur ce qu'on peut dire aussi sur
ses camarades sur ce qu'on peut
transmettre et cetera donc là il y a
vraiment oui oui quelque chose à faire
en tout cas au niveau de de l'éducation
nationale qui se met en place et
évidemment la formation prend sous
quelle forme sous forme de formation
pour les enseignants par exemple ou
d'intervention auprès des élèves et et
le conseil qu'on peut donner aux parents
alors justement c'est bien de de
vérifier un petit peu ce que fait son
son enfant parce que je présume que le
cyberharcèlement c'est plutôt pour les
collégiens les lycéens c'est pas
forcément pour les écolers les réseaux
sociaux sont interdits au 13 ans voilà
qu'avant ils ont pas leur page sur un
certain site mais en principe oui c'est
ça c'est les collégien lycéen quel
conseil on peut donner aux parents c'est
pas simple d'être on n'est pas forcément
derrière l'enfant regarder ce qu'il fait
sur le D c'est très compliqué quand on a
affaire à des adolescents c'est sûr
qu'ils apprécient fort peu d'avoir les
parents comme amis ou comme contact mais
c'est en tout cas les informer des
dangers euh voir paramétrer avec eux
leur compte peut-être faire la enfin
participer à la création du compte les
accompagner et puis leur rappeler que
bah on peut pas tout dire on peut pas
tout faire sur Internet c'est une une
place publique et tout ce qui se fait
sur la sur la toile bah a tendance à y
rester quand on a préparé cette émission
de cyberhcèlement vous me parlez
notamment du sexting SAG oui c'est
quelque chose qui se développe on le
voit depuis l'année dernière c'est le
fait que des jeunes
envoie des photos alors parfois sans
forcément sans être sous la pression de
quelqu'un mais ça peut être une jeune
fille qui envoie une photo d'elle un
petit peu dédudée un copain qui va
l'utiliser la transmettre à ses amis la
photo circule bon voilà et parfois ça se
fait aussi sous la contrainte donc des
jeunes qui sont amenés à à poser dans
des voilà de manière subjective et la
photo est utilisée et détournée alors
les les deux numéros verts donc stop
parcellement et net écoute le premier
numéro vert qui est assez long mais qui
devrait être raccourci la ministre l'a
promis dans quelques semaines ça devrait
plus être que quatre chiffres ce qui
serait plutôt une bonne nouvelle parce
que pour l'instant c'est un chiffre
c'est un 0800 à rallonge au ministère en
France il y a eu un peu plus de
3619 appels qui ont été reçus en 2014
sur le numéro vert de stop harcèlement
1000 appels concernit de demandes qui ne
relevait pas du du harcèlement donc ça
fait plus de
2500 appels est-ce que vous au niveau de
l'Académie vous constatez aussi que les
gens décrochent plus facilement leur
téléphone pour peut-être ne serait-ce
que poser des questions donc l'année
scolaire dernière effectivement on a eu
une une augmentation euh euh assez
sensible he de du nombre d'appels et ça
semble se stabiliser là cette année euh
mais en même temps faut faut bien dire
aux parents qu'il n'hésitent surtout pas
à appeler euh qui s'autorisent à appeler
il se posent des questions ils appellent
il y a des des professionnels
au au téléphone là qui sont là justement
pour les aider à évaluer euh la
difficulté est-ce qu'on est bien dans du
harcèlement à les conseiller et puis à
quand effectivement ils évaluent
ensemble que l'enfant subit du
harcèlement donc à rebasculer sur sur
nos services vous pensez que les parents
des fois peuvent hésiter à appeler parce
que par honte aussi de dire
on va se on va se moquer de moi on va me
on va voilà parce que j'ai pas su réagir
c'est toujours le principe je crois
qu'il est important d'insister sur le le
fait qu'il est normal que les parents
culpabilisent sils apprennent que leur
enfant est harcelé mais que c'est
compliqué de déceler les signes
d'harcèlement quand on pas
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure c'est
qu'il faut absolument que le harcèlement
rentre dans les hypothèses àosé par les
parents pour ça pour essayer de
comprendre ce que pourquoi leur enfant
est différent je dirais de de l'enfant
et depuis quelques semaines voir
quelques mois de l'enfant qui qu'ils ont
pu connaître et et ensuite qui se
renseignent les sites du ministère sont
sont vraiment très accessible et très
bien fait il est important de rappeler
que le site du ministère a été refondu
et qu'il est vraiment très simple et
très
fonctionnel voilà vous allez sur le site
vous avez vous êtes parents vous êtes
élèves et après vous êtes guidé il y a
des des fois au questions qui sont
extrêmement intéressantes et on trouve
plein de solutions sur le site internet
il se retourne vers les établissements
scolaires et si ça reste compliqué parce
que c'est un phénomène compliqué à
prendre en charge qui n'hésite surtout
pas à
téléphoner des enfin pour pour justement
échanger avec des professionnels qui
sont là pour eux et et malgré tout la
France a encore beaucoup de retard he
quand on on pense au
P non mais on pense aux pays de l'Europe
du Nord comme la Suède ou la Finlande
qui sont très avancés ça fait 40 ans que
eux parle du harcèlement à l'école en
France ça fait quelques annéés ça fait
quelques années après ils ont mis 13 ans
quand même en Norvège pour faire
diminuer le taux donc bon on a encore un
petit peu de travail devant nous et moi
je compte beaucoup sur la la formation
en tout cas des équipes et et les
actions de prévention de manière à
lutter contre le harcèlement bon le
traiter c'est une bonne chose si on
pouvait vraiment l'éviter ça serait
encore mieux quand vous étiez venus en
plateau hein toutes les trois il y a un
peu plus d'un an je vous avais demandé
si c'était tabou est-ce que c'est
toujours aussi tabou le harcèlement à
l'école petit peu moins moins beaucoup
c'est beaucoup moins tabou beaucoup
moins tabou néanmoins le passage obligé
comme me montrer dans le reportage c'est
vraiment la relation avec ses camarades
la relation avec les copains dans la
cour ça c'est un passage obligé c'est
plus ou moins facile selon les
personnalités mais en tout cas ça ça ne
doit pas générer de la souffrance ça
peut être un petit peu compliqué mais en
tout cas ça doit pas générer de la
souffrance dès l'instant c'est l'école
de la vie mais c'est pas l'école de de
la douleur hein non plus ex tout à fait
merci en tout cas à vous trois d'être
venu sur le le plateau je voudrais
rappeler les les numéros verts il y a un
placard qui va s'afficher sur le numéro
stop stop harcèlement le 0808 807 010
vous pouvez également aller sur le site
du du ministère de l'Éducation nationale
consacré au harcèlement à l'école qui
est un site extrêmement bien fait très
pédagogique où vous trouverez à la fois
des témoignage de professionnels et à la
fois beaucoup de de renseignement il est
important également de rappeler que
depuis le 4 août 2014 le harcèlement
moral est explicitement est reconnu
comme un un délit et puis je voulais
aussi souligner qu'en avril 2015 ce sera
la 2e édition du Prix mob
mobilisons-nous contre le harcèlement
comme en 2014 les productions des élèves
serviront aussi d'outils de prévention
dans dans les écoles ça fonctionne ah ça
fonctionne très très bien on a eu de
très très belles réalisations cette
année encore et celle de l'année
dernière était vraiment fantastique on
suivra ça merci beaucoup d'être venu en
plateau ce numéro du 78 société se
termine je souhaite une excellente
soirée à très
bientôt